[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro de dimanche en politique
plus haut que la rosa centrale il y
avait une grande flamme qui montait
entre deux clochers avec des tourbillons
d'étincelles ce passage de notre dame de
paris de victor hugo est devenu triste
réalité le 15 avril il y a tout juste
vingt jours
vous vous souvenez tous de ces images un
feu qui part des combles une flèche qui
s'effondre et un monument historique qui
menacent de vaciller depuis l'émotion
s'est emparée de tous les français et
bien au delà
alors comment préserver notre patrimoine
notamment lors des nécessaires chantier
de restauration
peut-on vraiment protéger de tels
édifices comment expliquer l'immense
émotion mais aussi l'élan de générosité
après l incendie
notre dame de paris va-t-elle devenir
l'arbre qui cache la forêt d'un
patrimoine en péril
peut-on sauvegarder tous nos monuments
et à quel prix autant de questions qu'on
se pose ce dimanche matin en direct avec
nos invités anne matthes auront bonjour
vous êtes la directrice régionale des
affaires culturelles en bourgogne
franche comté merci d'être avec nous dit
bédel bonjour vous êtes le délégué
régional de la fondation du patrimoine à
ce titre l'un des organismes qui
collectent des dons pour notre dame de
paris
mais pas seulement vous nous le dira et
certainement renaud françois bonjour
vous êtes conservateur aux hospices de
beaune qui ont connu un incendie de leur
toiture en 2008 on y reviendra également
avec vous paul godard bonjour bonjour
vous êtes architecte à dijon vous avez
présenté à un projet de reconstruction
quelques jours seulement après l
incendie on en parlera bien sûr ensemble
merci à tous d'avoir accepté cette
invitation est vous qui vous nous
regardez vous pouvez bien sûr commenter
cette émission en direct sur les réseaux
sociaux avec le hashtag jean paul
bourgogne j'ai envie de vous demander
parce qu'on vient de voir ces images
admettront quel a été votre sentiment
quand vous avez vu ce feu dans cette
cathédrale vous êtes tous ici autour de
la table des passionnés du patrimoine
quel a été votre sentiment personnel je
m'adresse pas à la directrice régionale
des affaires culturelles c'est quelque
chose à d'abord testé d'incompréhension
l'impression que c'est pas possible
parce que cette cathédrale est là depuis
des siècles et qu'on a l'impression
qu'elle elle est immortelle et là
c'était vraiment une association de
drame ni bédel votre sentiment
émotion et en même temps comprendre que
rien n'était ternel et qu'un problème
peut vite arriver et qu'il faut vraiment
se garantir contre ces problèmes
willow françois moi ça m'a rappelé et
bien sûr les hospices de beaune ont
chanté restauration et on sait que les
départs de feu on ne faut les traiter
immédiatement et du coup c'est une
grande émotion en 10 ans on est passé à
côté de quelque chose de catastrophique
oh le bel a beaucoup beaucoup de
tristesse et en même temps une sorte de
fascination devant ce feu keane qui
n'arrête pas de brûler presqu'un peu
captée par l'image il ya eu un sentiment
parfois un peu ambivalent chez beaucoup
de personnes qui regardaient ces images
terrifiantes ça pose évidemment et bruno
françois le disent elle la question de
la préservation de notre patrimoine au
sein même des chantiers de restauration
presque un paradoxe on a besoin de ces
chantiers pour sauver et protéger notre
patrimoine et en même temps ils sont
toujours un risque qu'on a vu on va
parler des hospices de beaune dans un
instant mais il ya eu d'autres cas dans
l'histoire beaucoup ou quand il ya des
chantiers il ya des risques d'incendié
admettront vous à la drac vous vous êtes
vigilant aussi à ces questions là alors
c'est pas que à l'adac il y à des pc
vous colle dresse contre sécurité oui
des travaux mais il ya aussi le
groupement des monuments historiques
il ya aussi des processus de marchés
publics des obligations pour gérer la
sécurité des chantiers et il faut
relativiser aussi le nombre de chantiers
monument historique en france plus de
40000 monuments historiques inscrits et
classés plus de 22500 qui appartiennent
aux collectivités publiques
près d'eux
dix quinze mille chantiers de
restauration et de protection
et quand même heureusement très peu des
protocoles de sécurité des vigilances
très normé des personnels des experts
très attentif des entreprises monuments
historiques très attentive aussi voilà
mais est ce qu'on y pense on imagine
qu'on y pense
conques évidemment il ya des normes de
sécurité tout le monde prend les
précautions nécessaires personne n'en
doute en fait mais on sait que le risque
potentiel est là et ça j'imagine que
quand vous vous allez sur vous vous
rendez sur des visites de chantier
j'imagine que vous c'est quelque chose
auquel vous pensez
oui mais tout est enfin en ont on n'y
pense pas tout le temps parce que c'est
ça serait un handicap on ne force rien
donc on n'y pense pas on anticipe c'est
pas la même chose
paul godard sur ces chantiers de
restauration auquel vous pouvez parfois
participé comme architecte est ce que
c'est une question que vous vous posez
est ce que vous y pensez avant même la
110 à notre dame
c'est une question capitale parce que un
petit peu comme dans l'aviation si vous
voulez le risque c'est au décollage et
quand on fait un chantier quand on quand
on démarre un chantier le plus gros
risque c'est quand on quand on quand on
construit quand on rénove lorsque le
bâtiment va être mis en route ou
lorsqu'il va vraiment être utilisé le
risque va disparaître donc on est
attentif à toute la mise en oeuvre à la
fois des matériaux aux soins
des artisans à contrôler véritablement
le que ce soit le feu que ce soit plein
d'autres choses autour d'un chantier
donc la période du chantier
c'est une période qui va être pour nous
extrêmement intense et sur lequel on va
devoir être très très vigilant avec oui
un peu comme une opération jaillir à
coeur ouvert c'est à dire que c'est
jamais anodin quoi exactement s'est
jamais anodin c'est pour ça que l'
incendie intervient pendant 1 sur un
chantier de rénovation pour notre adams
et ça montre toute la délicatesse qu'on
doit apporter à la sécurité pendant un
chantier au nom françois pourtant ces
chantiers ils sont nécessaires pour bien
sauvegarder notre patrimoine ils sont à
la fois la meilleure chance de
sauvegarder et en même temps le risque
permanent que quelque chose arrive
surviennent parce que l'erreur
l'erreur humaine peut être malgré toutes
les précautions prises l'erreur humaine
peut arriver aussi
en l'occurrence aux hospices de beaune
donc nous on avait une voiture qui avait
besoin on va revoir des images le
lendemain de la centif d'être refaite et
puis parce que bon les ardoises étaient
cuites n'assurait plus donc l'étanchéité
du couvert et donc il ya eu deux départs
de feu en fait un en 2008 on va en 2008
un d'origine chimique
en fait c'est incitatif et de lutte de
lynx ont enflammé qu'à enflammer âge qui
font tout de suite qui se sont propagés
donc aux produits de peinture et ensuite
au au plancher bois qui avait été mis en
protection et le second c'était sur un
point chaud sur une lucarne qui venait
d'être enfin où il y avait du plomb et
vous savez était soudée et donc en
pleine journée et donc bah c'est grâce à
l'intervention des personnes qui étaient
sur place alors pour le premier départ
de feu c'était le soir et avant nous on
a un concierge h24 donc qui est sûre les
auspices puis les voisins si je crois
qu'ils ont qu'il a vu le deuxième
incendie vie mais pour le premier c'est
le sait grâce aux concierges sur place
avec la détection incendie et le relais
aussi qu'on a au niveau de l'hôpital
puisque tout est relayée sur la centrale
de l'hôpital
j'imagine évidemment que vous avez vu la
toiture de notre-dame partir en fumée ça
vous a rappelé des choses est ce que
depuis 2008
vous avez changé votre regard sur ces
travaux de restauration est ce que de
nouvelles sécurisation ont été mises en
place pour éviter que ces choses se
reproduit ce que ça aurait pu être bien
plus grave
oui tout à fait parce que nous aussi ça
a pris à côté du clocher et à chaque
fois c'est parce que ça a été pris au
tout début du départ de feu que les
incendies a peut être circonscrit ça
c'est très important
c'est pouvoir intervenir rapidement et
en ciblant bien le lieu du départ de feu
en fait l'ailé nous ça fait des années
que le le risque feu et pris en compte
aux hospices de beaune
on a des procédures on a aussi vidé tous
les greniers des objets mobiliers qui se
trouvait pour éliminer le potentiel
calorifique ça c'est une chose très
importante aussi
on a ensuite d'un dès la détection dans
tout l'est tout partout dans les combles
partout dans toutes les salles donc avec
un relais sur une centrale
on a une personnage 24 donc mais on a
aussi un plan de sauvegarde c'est à dire
que les oeuvres sont enfin notez enfin
que dire repérer pour être retirée
rapidement avant de caler de feu juste
au dessus et mais bon tout cela doit
être revisitée en permanence parce que
c'est de la prévention et on s'endort un
peu parfois quand elle rien eu mais donc
le las c'est vraiment une piqûre de
rappel pour repartir et s'interroger à
nouveau dit bébel vous qui toute l'année
et c'est préserver le patrimoine à la
fondation du patrimoine
c'est évidemment vous dites c'est quand
même bien dommage de faire les travaux
de restauration pour finir comme ça
c'est sûr mais en même temps je trouve
que ça montre que les choses sont pas
pérennes qu'il faut faire très attention
et la sécurité aussi moi qui viens du
monde de l'entreprise on faisait des
répétitions tous les mois sur les
problèmes de sécurité
parce qu'après on croit que ça marche et
ça pas s'endormir disait bruno françois
parce que ça peut arriver et avoir des
pratiques récurrentes pour simuler des
incidents et vérifier que
les moyens et les hommes sont bien
adaptés à la situation
est ce qu'on disait and made man 10 par
rapport à tous les chantiers qui a
évidemment ça n'arrive pas souvent mais
alors soit c'est un phénomène de loupe
avec les médias soit c'est le hasard du
calendrier mais il ya ya pas si
longtemps une église en franche comté
récemment les termes de bourbon-lancy
quelques le lendemain ou le surlendemain
de de ce qui s'est passé de l'incendié à
notre dame de paris
on voit quand même que ce sont des
choses qui existent et qu'il faut de
plus en plus prendre en compte ça veut
dire que vous allez il ya aujourd'hui a
été lancée par le ministère de la
culture and audit des la sécurité dans
les cathédrales est ce que ça veut dire
que vous allez renforcer les normes de
sécurité dans les mois qui viennent que
ce soit pendant les chantiers ou en
dehors avec évidemment les questions de
dallaire 510 alors notre ministre franck
riester a bien entendu lancer plutôt une
campagne de vérification puisque ces
mesures de prévention elle existe c'est
roddick
c'est d'ailleurs le plan de prévention
des objets qui ont permis quand même de
sauver les collections de notre dame
il faut souligner aussi le
l'engagement des des pompiers et sauver
des rallys de secours incendie et le
lien c'est les plans de sauvetage
les exercices d'évacuation et puis aussi
la sécurité de tous les établissements
qui reçoivent du public et qui ont
permis ce protocole a permis qu'il n'y
ait pas de blessés mais maintenant aussi
sans doute essayer d'anticiper pour que
ça n'arrive pas même si effectivement
les pompiers ont été extraordinaires
pendant l' incendie
l'idéal aurait été sans doute que le feu
n'a n'arrive pas oui alors que les cas
qu'ils apprennent plus vite plus
rapidement vous laissez agir plus vite
on est tous
on est tous partisans du risque non mais
on sait qu'il n'existe pas forcément
est ce que ça veut dire que vous allez
faire le tour des monuments revoir les
systèmes de sécurité vérifier que tout
fonctionne pas ne pas s'endormir à ce
que disait bruno françois bien entendu
mais je pense que on ne sait jamais
endormi fins et il ya un risque quand il
n'y a pas d'évènement c'est vrai que
pendant un temps on peut ne pas y penser
même si je sais que les protocoles vous
l'avez dit hein
j'entends mais est-ce qu'il faut pas
sans cesse finalement être sur le qui
vive
alors on a au ministère de la culture un
inspecteur chargé de la sécurité qui
régulièrement avec les comités d'hygiène
et sécurité avec les représentants du
personnel parce que le sujet de la 110
pendant les travaux c'est aussi le sujet
de l' incendie et des risques
d'ouverture au public et des conditions
de travail des agents bien sûr donc on
est tous sensibilisés vraiment par par
ce risque qui existe partout tout le
temps et on a vraiment des protocoles
très régulier effectivement le premier
réflexe ça a été de dire moi le
lendemain de notre dame j'ai regardé
quels étaient les chantiers
dans les cathédrales de la bourgogne
franche comté il y en a quatre
il ya un an de travaux de charpente
donc on vérifie avec l'architecte des
bâtiments de france et l'architecte en
chef des monuments historiques où ils en
sont on vérifie bien sûr donc mais ne
rien oui bien sûr j'aimerais qu'on
évoque on a évoqué l'émotion autour de
cet incendie il ya vingt jours
maintenant j'aimerais qu'on évoque la
générosité du modèle plus d'un milliards
récoltés en quelques jours seulement les
dons continuent à arriver à la fondation
de france et aux autres organismes qui
la fondation de france oui et la
fondation du patrimoine la fondation
notre dame
enfin les organismes qui récolte qui
sont chargés officiellement de récolter
de l'argent pour pour sauver cette
cathédrale et pour la reconstruire
est ce que vous êtes impressionné vous
qui passez votre votre année à récolter
des fonds pour sauver le patrimoine le
patrimoine de notre région aussi qui en
a besoin également
est-ce que vous avez été impressionnée
surpris dubitatifs chez pas
impressionner et d'une part impressionné
parce que quand même on a réagi
fondation du patrimoine très rapidement
pour lancer une souscription pour notre
dame des landes marcel même le soin même
ont pratiquement dans la cité tendent à
lui dans le lendemain le site était
ouvert et je dirais on a eu déclic quand
même de certains grands donateurs
oui on va rentrer tout de suite la voix
ceci étant en termes de personnes
privées on était à 14 millions d'euros
quand même collecté oui le reste plus
d'un milliard donc on s'est aperçu que
en termes de collecte de personnes
privées c'est autant pour la fondation
du patrimoine dans une année ça doit
vous faire plaisir vous qui êtes
précieux du patrimoine que que
finalement les gens se soient autant
mobilisé on ne croyait presque pas enfin
on a été un peu surpris d'une telle
mobilisation bruno franchement non je
suis pas trop surpris parce que je pense
que c'est un émincé un élan de
générosité c'est vraiment très choquant
quand on voit ce monument partir en
flammes et je crois que les gens
vraiment envie de contribuer à sa
rénovation à sa restauration parce qu'il
ya des gros besoins quand même avec de
gros dégâts commis sans fin qui y ont
été faits par le feu et aussi par
l'eau et les chutes aussi de charpente
qui ont bien sûr endommagé considéré ce
que vous comprenez les polémiques qui
sont nés dans la foulée autour de tout
cet argent pour finalement un monument
alors qu'il ya peut-être d'autres causes
qui mériteraient je sais pas qui
souhaitent s'exprimer
jb oui je peux m'exprimer on peut se
dire c'est l'arbre qui cache la forêt
notre dame
et puis en même temps on peut se dire
mais avec notre dame
on va essayer de faire mieux et moi j'en
suis un autre coach je pensais aussi aux
polémiques autour des causes
humanitaires par exemple qui aurait pu
avoir de telles de telles sommes
y compris de la part des généraux dodo
lather que vous évoquez au début mon
point de vue est complémentaire si je
mens je rappelle quand même que l'argent
qui est qui vient pour le patrimoine
génère de l'activité pour des
entreprises sur des savoir faire
précieux
donc ça et qu'on souhaite conserver sa
crème fouras a fait venir des touristes
vous allez aussi écouter notre dame 15
millions de personnes visitaient mais
nous on a d'autres édifices là aussi qui
qui demandent des visites donc on fait
du beau et de l'attractivité
cette attractivité c'est aussi de
l'économie d'accord et puis on essaye
aussi de faire des événements sympa pour
les collectes de dons sur toute la
bourgogne franche comté
donc je dirais sont des valeurs
positives et cet argent qui servent aux
entreprises peut permettre de financer
de l'économie sociale et solidaire par
bon mais on a besoin d'activité en
france donc profitons de notre
patrimoine pour générer de l'activité
alors justement est ce que notre dame
c'est l'arbre qui cache la forêt
animateurs on est ce que tout notre
patrimoine a besoin de restauration
finalement mais là il ya un engouement
particulier parce qu'on a vu ces images
qui qui qui nous ont tous marqué oui
alors c'est l'arbre qui cache la forêt
par la communication qui en effet parce
qu'enfin on parle de 400 millions
d'euros du budget du ministère de la
culture mais si on compte la formation
de tous les experts liên pêche aliot
l'entretien des 25000 monuments
historiques appartiennent aux
collectivités
le centre des monuments nationaux
son entretien la valorisation du
patrimoine les salaires des
conservateurs ont néamoins coup plus de
2 milliards d'euros de crédits publics
et de crédits de l'état parce que toutes
les préfectures sont quasiment monuments
historiques lâchement ont peut-être
qu'on ne se rend pas compte notre dame à
montrer parce que c'est à paris parce
que c'est un symbole a montré la force
du patrimoine
l'attachement des français ont des
pattes de des français et la force du
patrimoine dans une ville mais je crois
qu on peut parler ici
auditionné aux gens qui habite besançon
à cette richesse de toute la région est
en fait c'est très identitaire on est
d'une région on aime son patrimoine de
données pour notre dame de paris mais on
peut aussi penser que dans notre région
il ya des monuments qui ont besoin de
restauration
mais il ya des monuments qui ont besoin
de restauration et l'état et les
collectivités et les particuliers les
propriétaires privés consacre des
crédits n'ya pas zéro il n'y a pas tout
pour notre dame et 0 pour la
restauration des monuments historiques
ya énormément d'argent sur la
restauration des mouvements sociaux se
sait dichotomie entre ce qui se passe à
notre dame de paris et puis tous ces
monuments stéphane bern avec dubé d'elle
et la fondation du patrimoine forme se
démène pour essayer d'expliquer qu'il ya
plein de choses qui si on n'y fait pas
attention peuvent disparaître
on a une un pays qui est très riche en
patrimoine et forcément on ne peut pas
tout entre tes en même temps mais
néanmoins ya quand même une attention de
tous les jours à la fois de l'état des
collectivités des conservateurs pour pas
sauvegarder ce patrimoine
alors c'est vrai qu'il faudrait plus de
moyens parce que on aimerait que tout
soit rutilant et est en très bon état
tout le temps mais bon c'est vrai et
après il ya aussi le temps du chantier
qui est très long on vient parler de
temps dans un instant
et c'est important de dire mais bon je
suis pas surpris de l'engouement des
gens puissent aussi un édifice
représentative du culte catholique et
donc c'est quand même la première
cathédrale de france donc c'est
emblématique est ce que ça peut
entraîner
vous avez commencé à le dire tout à
l'heure je vous ai coupé libéral mais
est ce que ça peut entraîner un
engouement pour aussi pour d autres
lieux de patrimoine et finalement se
dire que on y est plus attachés que ce
qu'on pensait et justement sur cet
événement il faut essayer de rebondir
il ya plusieurs façon de rebondir par
exemple le nombre de projets berne 2019
moi j'aimerais qu'il soit en
augmentation par rapport à ce qu'on a
fait l'an dernier n'est ce pas madame la
directrice
parce que je pense que c'est l'occasion
de montrer la commune une communication
sur je sais pas une trentaine d'édifices
en bourgogne franche comté qui ont toute
leur valeur toutes leurs différences
l'autre point qu'on pourrait imaginer
c'est au sujet des entreprises
de l'ensemble des artisans vous pourrez
mieux mettre en valeur de faire aussi
plus de jeunes qui participent à la
formation etc reconnaissance de
formation on pourrait avoir un label
patrimoine pour les entreprises par
exemple
bon donc c'est l'idée comment peut-on
rebondir pour faire mieux voilà un mal
pour un bien
j'en veux dire en quelque sorte en
quelque sorte même si tout le monde sur
un préféré éviter l'incendié à notre
d'harry on peut parler de l'économie
numérique aussi avec le patrimoine donc
on a quelques sujets d'avenir
intéressant donc si notre dame peut nous
dire ça comme ça
paul godard vous vous avait présenté un
projet on va en parler parce que vous
êtes architecte à dijon et et votre
cabinet a présenté un projet très
rapidement derrière avec avec quand même
en arrière fond les propos du président
de la république rebâtir notre dame en
cinq ans et puis la question de la
question du coût évidemment de de cette
reconstruction même si on a vu qu'ils
aient déjà plus d'un milliard qui est
arrivé dans les caisses pour financer
cette reconstruction
alors pourquoi vous avez un petit
sourire en coin quand vous regardez
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez lancé ce
projet pourquoi aussi vite allés est-ce
que c'est un coup de com ou est-ce que
vous vous aviez envie de réaliser ce
projet vraiment en fait il ya deux
choses déjà nous nous les architectes
ont aidé éternel optimiste c'est à dire
que c'est bien
après la pluie le beau temps faut c'est
ce qu'on se dit et finalement cette
arrivée d'argent etc non l'a pas vécu
vraiment comme un scandale
au contraire on s'est dit c'est
l'occasion de ramener de l'argent pour
le patrimoine et de la même manière avec
avec le projet qu'on a suggéré on s'est
dit c'est l'occasion de parler de notre
métier d'architecte
on a entendu un tas de d'experts dans
les médias qui ont dit ouh là là il faut
absolument reconstruire à l'identique
il faut faire la même chose et ses roues
c'est pas votre monnaie ce que voulait
mourir en deux mots on voit les images
en quoi ça consiste
nous si vous voulez ce qu'on sait lycée
on peut faire autre chose c'est possible
de faire autre chose et le patrimoine
c'est une succès c'est une succession de
du temps qui passe et c'est d'oeuvres
d'artistes de couches superposées j'ai
envie de dire de et donc nous l'idée
qu'on a qu'on a qu'on a qu'on a donnée
c'est tout simplement d'imaginer une
autre une autre toiture non pas par sa
forme mais par son aspect qui pourrait
être vitré dans lequel on pourrait avoir
une trace de cet événement qui nous a
tous marqués c'est à dire de dire que ce
qu on va reconstruire on l'a reconstruit
parce qu'il est arrivé quelque chose de
dramatique
ce fameux lundi au carrelet une trace de
ce qui s'est passé et puis privilégié
aussi des visites sur le toit qui
permettrait de désengorger aussi notre
dame par moments il ya qu'il ya quand
même pas que j'espère giron tueur à
faire vibrer avec ce nouveau projet on
pouvait même faire un étendard au
patrimoine s'aider eux-mêmes générer des
visites qui pourrait ramener de l'argent
pour notamment la vendre pour financer
le reste des le reste des bâtiments en
france où le reste des monuments en
france on pourrait imaginer que cet
élément vitré ou ou toute autre sorte un
d'ailleurs ne laissait pas figé mais le
question combien ça coûte
si tenté que le projet soit chiffré et
combien de temps pour réaliser selon
vous l'architecte alors nous déjà on n'a
pas chiffré le projet pour la bonne et
simple raison que ce con c'était juste
une un pavé dans la mare comment comment
et demi on pense que l'argent est
largement suffisant titre de comparaison
nous ont construit un collège de 700
étudiants de 700 collégiens
on a besoin de 13 millions d'euros pour
construire un collège de 2,7 pour cette
cité les contre-attaqués moi c'est pas
tout à fait les mêmes
donc je pense que pour avec un milliard
on va pouvoir se débrouiller et le temps
et ensuite sur le temps ces cinq sens et
raisonnable c'est pour le temps de la
construction
on pense que c'est raisonnable ce qui
n'est pas raisonnable c'est la
démocratie qui va être derrière c'est
tout ce qui va engendrer sur les
expertises et la bureaucratie de manière
générale qui va prendre du temps
j'aimerais entendre ceux qui sont autour
de vous à la fois sur le projet de pôle
godard est ce que c'est quelque chose
qui vous semblent réalistes et est-ce
qu'il faut reconstruire notre dame à
l'identique ou paulo france
votre point de vue à vous un personnel
ont tenté d'engager personnes bah moi je
suis pas contre utiliser d'autres
matériaux mais quand même avoir un
visuel à peu près identique ce qu'il
faut par contre ce qu'il faut pas
oublier c'est que en dessous on a quand
même tout un bâtiment à consolider
puisque le l'incendide a fortement
endommagé
et ça c'est très important et c'est un
temps qui n'est pas incompressibles
libérèrent il faut reconstruire à
l'identique notre dame où il faut je
crois qu'il faudrait faire un concours
abbas à son parti pour avoir de bonnes
idées
après les donatrices et donateurs que
j'ai pu croiser sont plutôt pour la
reconstruction à l'identique oui c'est
la majorité de français leur raquette
opinion et je demanderai quand même en
terme d'opinion c'est à celles et ceux
qui ont donné ils s'assemblent
importantes semblent avoir une voix un
peu prépondérante mais en même temps
l'imagination la créativité et qui font
la force de la france pourquoi pas
admettons j'entends votre droit de
réserve mais quand même entre quelque
chose de moderne constructions
contemporaines qui pourrait marquer une
époque aussi comme l'a fait viollet le
duc avant son temps ou la reconstruction
à l'identique vous avez une préférence
ou là j'ai envie de dire de toute façon
ministère de la culture
il ya qu à voir avec le mucem ça fait
très longtemps elle est architecte en
chef aussi ça fait très longtemps qu'on
oppose pas la reconstruction à
l'identique et l' architecture
contemporaine
mais là on touche un bâtiment aliments
oui mais ce qui est intéressant ce qui
est passionnant c'est le les échanges
des experts est ce qu'ils sont c'est
vrai que c'est intéressant d'avoir que
des jeunes architectes
alors ce qui est un peu dommage c'est
que vous ayez l'impression qui faillit
lancé un pavé dans la mare
c'est vraiment ça fait partie de la
formation des architectes du patrimoine
que de se poser la question et les
architectes en chef
il s'impose tout le temps et je pense
que oui c'était intéressant en ligne
parce que ça fait de la communication
quand on voit quand on voit on pourrait
penser à quelque chose de moderne
pourrait ne pas être forcément très beau
sur une cathédrale gothique et quand on
voit ça on se dit ah bah finalement il
ya quelque chose qui qui rend bien ça
dénature pas complètement le bâtiment
enfin voila j'ai mon point de vue de
deux novices en patrimoine le temps pour
reconstruire notre dame est ce que vous
avez un avis sur la question on a
entendu paul bell a requis 5 ans c'est
possible mais attention à la
paperasserie aux complications
administratives qui existent aussi
hoyau françois dit que le temps me
paraît court même pour la boxe en bonne
et simple raison c'est qu'on compare pas
d'un money finlande d'intérêt d'un
terrain vague c'est qu'on a une
restauration a mené avant de pouvoir
construire quelque chose dessus
donc c'est ça pour quoi intéresser pas
mal experts mais ça me paraît la
préparation est toujours un temps
important
oui parce que construire l'appareil est
un projet réussi un projet mal préparée
est en général un projet qui coûte plus
cher et dont les résultats sont pas
satisfaisants palda construit en béton
mais généralement par exemple pour un
bâtiment landes à un immeuble on va
mettre deux ans à le construire
mais par contre on va mettre deux ans
d'études pour le préparer donc c'est la
préparation qui est à peu près
équivalente au temps constructible car
vous dites quoi prudence ce peut-être
pas la peine de se précipiter quoi on
peut faire deux années plus si la pierre
si besoin
merci de notre dame merci à tous d'avoir
participé à cette émission d'ora accepté
de répondre à ces questions à débattre
aujourd'hui
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis chat
dans un instant le point sur l'actualité
régionale avec emmanuel pinsonneault tu
vis de la partie nationale de dimanche
en politique francis letellier reçoit
manon aubry tête de liste de la france
insoumise aux européennes
bon dimanche à tous sur france 3
[Musique]